hello and welcome to the program
today we'll be talking about the
situation in northern ireland
in december the representatives from
great britain and ireland signed a
declaration of principles to work toward
peace in the region today we'll talk
about that possible
with our guest father sean mcmanus who
founded the irish national caucus in
washington
it lobbies for justice and peace in
northern ireland father mcmanus was born
in northern ireland
also joining us is jamie dettmer
washington correspondent for the irish
sunday independent and the scotland on
sunday publications
he was born in england and has written
extensively on northern ireland
also with us is maureen merker president
of the ulster scott society
a genealogical historical society in the
u.s she was raised in northern ireland
but has lived in the us for 30 years
welcome to you all thank you in just a
few minutes we'll be taking questions
from our audience of high school
students who are in washington this week
on close-ups government studies program
and when we come to you we'd like you to
tell us your name and where you're from
but first we'll begin with a discussion
up here about the history of conflict in
northern ireland
we hear that this has been going on for
quite a while how did it begin
and why father mcmanus well it has its
roots
um like many other problems in the world
it has
roots in uh english british colonialism
uh ireland was england's very first
colony it was in ireland that the
british experimented
and learned the techniques of racism
discrimination
oppression that they took to america
don't forget
to your country they took it to india
they took it to the mideast that took it
all over the world and wherever the
british flag
has flown all over the world there has
been racism and discrimination
and oppression after all that's why you
americans kicked the british out of this
country
when did the conflict there begin and
what
the british in one form or another first
got a foothold in ireland
in 1169. so that's a long time ago folks
uh it's been almost a thousand years and
up until 1920
the british government controlled all of
ireland
and the center of british administration
in ireland
this is very important was not in
belfast but in dublin
and for centuries england ruled ireland
from dublin
as one economic geographic political
cultural entity and then in the
1916-1920 era
when britain realized they could no
longer hold all of the country
as they had for centuries they're
retreated
into the northeast corner the part of
ireland i'm from
and the carved out a little area there
of six
tiny counties a tiny little area
out of the whole of ireland because they
knew that in those six counties
there were a million pro-british people
a million protestants
who happened to be protestants to a half
a million catholic who were nationalists
and the deal was britain said look
to the protestants of northern ireland
we'll set you up here in this new
artificial entity that had never been
heard of before
in all of a thousand years of history
will set you up here in a position
of power run this area any way you like
as long as you keep it loyal to the
crown as long as you keep it
to the empire i think i've got to
interrupt there because i think that's
the most prejudiced uh
interpretation of the history of the
last 4 500 years in ireland
first of all in terms of the setting up
of northern ireland and the six counties
um you you're suggesting that it was
kind of scheme in london whereby london
decided they will carve out this area of
their own
they didn't really have much choice as
you well know in the 19th century
there was tremendous resistance from
protestants in northern ireland
who had uh who originally came from
scotland i agree in the 16th 17th
who had lived there for a long time and
you know perfectly well
that uh in the early part of the 20th
century it was made clear that
protestants would resist by force of
arms being pushed into a a republic
government
into one country uh with the catholics
in the south and it was clear that the
british government could not even rely
on the british army in northern ireland
to resist um uh protestants uh
uh you know no i don't know so i mean
it it isn't the case that the british
government sat there and decided to
carve out this nice little
enclave but they did they did by a
knight
of the british parliament now we can get
into multiple interpretations
it was the british government by the act
of ireland of 1920
that carved out and created that
artificial entity it was in the
protestants of northern ireland
the republic of ireland seceded from the
united kingdom
in 1921. northern ireland has
been an integral part of the united
kingdom since
1803 almost as long as the united states
has been a nation i think we have a very
different interpretation of this and
i would like to give you just a very
brief
background of northern ireland let me
say in the british isles there are two
nations
there is the united kingdom
and the republic of ireland the united
kingdom consists of scotland
england wales and northern ireland
we have a unitary form of government and
our government is at westminster in
london
the republic of ireland seceded from the
united kingdom
in 1921.
northern ireland has an area of 5
400 square miles a population of 1.6
million
and it was a haven for religious
dissenters
and much like the united states there's
a large
huguenot population in northern ireland
they came after the revocation of the
edict of nance
they were their wonderful group they
improved the linen industry and you've
all seen beautiful
irish linen the moravians came to
northern ireland they were palatine
germans and they built a most beautiful
village
called grace hill and grace hill
is almost identical to salem in north
carolina
then we have quakers who were chased out
of england at that time
and they built a beautiful village
called bessbrook
now the um and what about the catholics
samaria and say a few words about the
catholics well they're
really because we also live there you
know fine in 1600
uh in and three else northern ireland
was a separate kingdom right up until
that time
and let me tell you something i'm sorry
i don't have a map that i
own it was there was nobody in ulster
hardly anyone except around the borders
so almost everyone who is there today
are immigrants to
ulster i see the irish where no matter
where they come from they are primarily
where they must get us today i mean
these poor people must be totally
confused about this sudden eruption of
different interpretations of 400 years
of irish history
one of the problems of the whole
conflict is that the irish and the
british have very long memories
and there are a lot of grievances and
we're in a cycle
if you want almost of of revenge and
grievances
and remember depressions we now have a
situation where we've had a
conflict a low insurgency conflict in
northern ireland for 25 years we have
over 3 000 people dead
and there are attempts you know there
are attempts by various sites to try to
find a way
to end this conflict and it isn't that
helpful by going back to the edict
is important
the premiere albert reynolds said in the
speech in january
most people would accept that the
partition was wrong was ineffective was
unhelpful
but two wrongs but you didn't agree with
that at the beginning oh no
you disagree no i i wasn't arguing a
moral position about that i was
i was just trying to you know touch
touch you know
the tiller slightly yeah um that that
uh two wrongs don't make a right i
didn't say that you know the partition
is not helpful so what we've got to
discuss today here and what i think will
be far more helpful
for the close-up foundation students
we've been trying to find out how
we can travel and the most important
thing we can discuss in any problem
is who is in charge who controls if you
go into any city any town
and there's a problem your first
question must be who's in charge here
who's in control who writes the law who
controls the courts
and the police who controls all of that
in northern ireland
also who controls that in the republic
of ireland the
london government let me tell you that
when in the republic of ireland drafted
its constitution
in 1937 in articles two and three of
their constitution
they claim the whole island of ireland
and there has excuse me there has been
troubles ever since that let me also say
hold on hold on a second even though
there are recognized
international boundaries there are
recognized
international boundaries between what is
today's republic of ireland
and northern ireland let's go to our
first student questions and get you
involved
go ahead uh my question is directed at
any of you my name is dan howard from
st louis park minnesota and uh how do
you believe that the
portrayal of the ira in recent movies
has affected people's views about this
conflict
do you have any views on that have you
seen some of the movies or do you have
any opinions on the portrayal of the ira
um i've seen patriot games and it seems
as though they
they portray them as a bunch of
terrorists just out
just out for blood uh i
find most of the hollywood movies uh
concerning the ira and paramilitarism in
northern ireland whether it's pro ira or
anti-ira
singularly unhelpful and generally
ill-informed as well
uh patrick games actually annoyed me as
well uh
i mean the idea um you know the ira
tries to project itself as a disciplined
body
to a certain extent it is it doesn't
control all its
members that easily or that well
sometimes
i think that we have got to try to
keep much closer to the facts in those
movies than we do there's been a film
very recently
uh concerning the um gulf of bombers
um alleged yes falsely accused
the point of the movie yeah um well as i
understand it various facts are changed
and i think that's probably unhelpful uh
it it doesn't help people understand the
situation in northern well can i say
something on that
obviously it was a movie it wasn't meant
to be a historical
documentary it was a movie it was made
in hollywood okay
but i think it has done a number of
things it has made it very
clear to american people that british
law when it comes to northern ireland
is not normal that civil liberties are
suspended
that there's no uh there's no justice
and that if you're irish from northern
ireland
and living in england you're an accused
of a crime
you will not get justice and you live
in prison for years it has done that and
and not only you know the the one of the
characters jerry conlon was the star of
the main person
and paul hill featured in that movie and
paul hill
now who's now married to courtney
kennedy bobby kennedy's daughter
paul hill today as we speak is still
been victimized by a british court in
northern ireland they're still
trying to pin a false confession on them
and i think it's very important what
everyone's interpretation of the problem
in ireland to understand is that
the rights you people here from
minnesota and california
the basic rights you take for granted we
have never experienced them in northern
ireland
you have no right to a jewelry trial you
have no right to
privacy a coercer there are no
jury trials there are no jurial trials
and you wouldn't tolerate for a split
second what the ordinary people in
northern you have to give a slightly
broader picture because
you know as you know uh there's a kind
of dynamic a dynamic that no one is in
control of or has
no one has full control over in northern
ireland
and i will be the first to agree with
you that there has been a tremendous
corrosion and
corruption of the british judicial
system and particularly hold on hold on
no
well hold on father mcmahon you've got
to give a broader picture than that and
in northern ireland
um a lot of the changes in the law in
in northern ireland having non-jury
trials was in one way
as you well know provoked by terrorism
and the problem is
if you're a terrorist organization
you're trying to hold us laws come into
existence
um
is the reason that they have what is
called diplo
courts and it's they just have one judge
because there is intimidation of juries
and i know i would not be very happy to
sit on a jury
where some a terrorist was being tried
and this is why this was why these
courts were invented if there is an
appeal
then there are three judges and but then
again you cannot have
uh jury trials for these terrorists
the dynamic is too much intimidation on
the judicial side is this
that it is to the injury it is in the
interest of the ira
uh to provoke a reaction and a liberal
harsh reaction
from a democratic government and who's
the democratic father
there has never been a democratic
government ruling ireland
ever in centuries the english government
is not a democratic government in
northern ireland
never been a democrat who has elected
john major
to be in charge of northern ireland
father mcmanus you're trying to
suggest who has elected john
we're not talking about
it's not it's there's there is a
republic of ireland and the united
kingdom
and northern ireland is an integral part
of that united
have to say we'll have to st you speak
one at a time because we can't hear
what each person is saying all right
excuse me let's go to our next question
okay hi my name is nicole alvino and i'm
from orange county california
and i have a question that can be
directed to any of you
i know that there are great britain
troops stationed in northern ireland
and i want to know how you view these
troops and if they could
be seen as the first step to a possible
resolution
i would like to answer that and the
troops are united kingdom troops and
they are
in the united kingdom it would be the
equivalent of the united states troops
being in california
uh they are there because of terrorism
and otherwise they would not need to be
there
remember also that there are many ulster
regiments in the british army and they
have had a wonderful
wonderful reputation for
leading the united kingdom through many
wars
most of their field marshals in the
british army have been ulsterman and you
know their names like montgomery and
alexander et cetera
so the fact that the british army is in
the united kingdom
is where it should be it is not in
ireland and has not been in ireland
can i respond to that i'm as you can
tell
by my accent does it sound as if i'm
english
or british eh wouldn't you say by any
definition
i'm an irish guy okay i'm an irishman
from county for mana
ireland is a partition country 26
counties are controlled by the dublin
government
and the remaining six are still under
the rule of
the london government and since 1972
there's no government in in northern
ireland london rules directly
now the protestants of northern ireland
maintain that's
undemocratic and the catholics doubly
maintenance and democratic
the experiment of the london government
has never
worked in ireland it has been a disaster
for its own good name
it's a disaster for the protestants and
catholics and
what i want to see is
the protestants realizing that the
british game
in ireland is over it's truly over
london doesn't want them
london used them for centuries in their
own colonial interest
but if maureen had gone to london
like i did or to england and had more
protestants gone to
live in england they would have realized
that the moment they're in england
they're biddy or paddy it doesn't matter
whether whether they're a protestant
or a catholic and until the protestants
and catholics in northern ireland
realize that they themselves somehow
have to work
out this new solution
or a new future london hasn't got the
answer
london britain has given up all its
empire it's only left with two areas
the malvenus the falkland islands and
northern ireland
they're getting out of hong kong not
because uh
the majority wants them to leave in fact
the majority in hong kong wants
british rule to continue there's eight
million people in hong kong there's only
a million people
in northern ireland who want the british
slaves i mean
the impression you're giving these
people is inaccurate you're talking
about a colonial situation you have a
majority of people in northern ireland
who wish to retain their link with
britain they have a vote
there is a vote in northern ireland
there is a ballot box we're not talking
about a colony where people do not have
a vote
65 percent of the northern ireland
population vote for parties
regularly in elections parties which
wish to retain the link with great
britain
why do we have a problem uh why is there
a problem we have a problem because we
have
uh we have a parliamentary organization
where we have more than one parametric
organization but
finally the problem is because you have
an ira who wish to bomb
and shoot people into the center but
that's a part of the problem now let me
tell you what i think on that
the ira is definitely a problem a major
problem and they use violence and i
don't just diminish or dismiss that for
one minute
i condemn it outright unequivocally and
i condemn all violence whether it's the
ira
the british the loyalist terror gangs
whatever terror gang is operating in or
out of uniform
and the solution must lie in
non-violence but let me point out here
that in 1968 1969
there was a peaceful non-violent
movement a civil rights movement there
was no ira
where did the ira come from because the
british army came in and started
crushing it it was a marginalized ira
is more of a symptom than a cause the
cause is
injustice the cause is that ireland has
never been given a chance
to be a free i think it's the underlying
cause
of the ira regardless of what they might
say
is the fact that their goal is a
united ireland as is the goal of the
republic of ireland
and this is one of the very great
problems that we have
accepted the republic of ireland uh let
me also say
signed both the helsinki agreement and
the european community's treaty of rome
in 1976 and they are in violation of
both of those treaties the irish
government has made it perfectly clear
that they will get rid of articles two
and three which they claim to northern
ireland
and in a recent opinion poll in the
irish times 81
of uh the population indicated or it
suggested that 81
of the population of the south would
agree to give up their claim to northern
ireland well this has been but
for all these years this has been one of
the problems since 1937
this false claim to the territory of
northern ireland i'm sorry to go back
into history but the anglo-irish treaty
signed between london
and dublin agreed that the essential uh
long-term aim was a unity of the island
so i mean they hadn't done anything
extraordinary they had no i'm sorry
in the treaty in 1921 and so the
the south had not done anything
extraordinary by having articles two and
three
constitutions they did that's that is
student questions
that is uh hi my name is jennifer ielts
from st
paul minnesota and my question for any
one of you
is how come the media has forgotten
about the situation
in ireland i have a saying that had
had the communists been doing in
northern ireland what her majesty's
cover have
has been doing we would have been free
long ago
but because the oppressor in northern
ireland is england
america the american government and the
american media
turns a blind eye can i ask you in
general
can i ask you when you say the media do
you mean the american media or the
british media
the american i mean i think at times
that they uh i mean in the 1970s there
was certainly a great little coverage in
american media
about the problems in northern ireland i
think that uh as in britain
people get bored actually i think
readers and new people out there get
bored and don't want to hear
about the the problem again and again
it's been running so long
the guardian newspaper i mean the
british media you know obviously covers
this
this conflict in detail as the irish
media does as well
but uh the guardian newspaper which in
london which has a very political kind
of readership did a survey of its
readers and asked them
what are your what stories do you like
reading about what subjects are you most
interested in which subjects don't you
want to know about particularly or
you're fed up reading about
and northern ireland i'm afraid came
absolutely bottom even a very political
readership
but in america um i think it's sad that
the
uh the major american newspapers have
not had full-time correspondence
in ireland for a long time the new york
times has won in dublin
um the others send people out every now
and again and i think the problem with
that is that you get
ill-informed and i thought i think we
saw that in the uh jerry adams visit
uh last month when some of the american
coverage was quite extraordinary
there was a great deal of misrepresent
misrepresentation of facts
in the american coverage which irritated
not only
british tabloids in london but also
irish government politicians as well
next question hello my name is owen
rivas from centerfell california and my
question is directed to
father sean um this conflict has been
going on for centuries
do you see an end to long-standing
aggression and how will
catholics and protestants react once it
ends
well i would have to say that uh for the
first time in my
short or long life long last to you guys
long life
but for the first time in my life i
am beginning to be hopeful
i don't know how it's going to play out
but i i do believe that
right now in ireland at the moment
there's a new dynamic
uh which wasn't there before there's a
new potential
that hopefully will will bring about
some sort of a solution
and number one however you analyze the
problem in in ireland or northern
ireland
compromise has to be an essential part
because aspen has said here
there's a million protestants in
northern ireland i was lived in i was
reared among them there's a half a
million catholics
there's a split allegiance and there's a
real
there's a real problem it has that has
been confounded by the fact that for
many years the dublin government
and the london government haven't done
the right thing but right now
i'm inclined to think that the london
government
and the dublin government are beginning
maybe to try to do the right thing
and i would say that for the first time
the dublin government i think
uh i've always been very critical of the
dublin government but right now
i think this the present leader the
taoiseach as he's called
albert reynolds seems to be genuinely
and openly
and sincerely trying to reach out to get
everybody
involved in a solution so i think
for the first time ever i'm hopeful
could i please answer a question to you
and
tell you that there is a hope in
northern ireland
for example in northern ireland we have
two school systems there's the state
schools
and there are roman catholic parochial
schools and this is a sad situation in
that the children do not get to meet
each other
they mature without any cross-cultural
intervention but in
fairly recently parents themselves
who are very distressed about this have
initiated
a an integrated school system
and i think there are now 21
schools and 6 000 children are going
to these schools and i feel that this is
a a great step forward and hopefully
there will be more of them i'm i'm uh
pessimistic about the future of peace
and
this particular peace initiative for a
number of reasons
uh one maureen was talking about
integrated education in fact only one
percent
of northern ireland children are
educated in uh integrated schools and
that's after a tremendous effort for the
last 20 years
the chasms between the two communities i
think is wider
the statistics show that there are less
and less people living in
truly mixed areas voting districts are
now
you know almost totally either
protestant or catholic there are another
there are a number of obstacles to peace
in northern ireland one is you have got
to find
a form of words which will satisfy
nationalist desires
of the minority and the majority wish to
remain
linked tied to britain and no form of
words has
yet been constructed that can do that
they've been various attempts and
various solutions tried and proposed
the second thing that worries me is the
rise of
far more effective and far more deadly
protestant paramilitary groups
in northern ireland like the ouster
volunteer force and the auster
defence association um in about 1985-86
onwards
there were slowly you could see a new
leadership come
taking control of these paramilitary
units and they have become far more
effective far more deadly and they're
far better armed
uh the third the third major obstacle
is how far is the ira prepared to
compromise
and i suspect they're not prepared to
compromise very much on
saturday uh jerry adams made a speech at
the annual conference of sinn fein
yardesh
where he said that republicans would
have to prepare for
another phase adapt to a new phase in
the conflict to achieve republican goals
and he put that at two or three years
i'm not too sure that jerry adams
even if he is a delve as some suggests
he
is can deliver the ira on a compromised
agreement
um there is one other obstacle and that
is in the house of commons that john
major the british prime minister
has a very has a very slim majority and
has very little room for maneuver
he is not lord of all he surveys in the
conservative party
he has a ramp of about 60 right-wing
rebellious fractious mps
who are very anti-uh the european
community for example
and in the summer john major had to turn
to support to the ouster unionist mps in
the house of commons
he cannot afford to alienate those mps
if he wishes to
retain control of the conservative party
in parliament or get through european
legislation
so i am very worried and one of my
worries is that northern ireland may be
worse off
after this peace process if it collapses
badly than it was before
let's go to our next question hi my name
is mark
corridor from huntington beach
california and i was wondering
um you might not agree with me but it
seems to me that this struggle in
northern ireland
is very similar to that of uh the
palestinians and
israelites in israel on the west bank
and so i was wondering do you think that
the
u.n should step in and maybe help
mediate this uh
struggle that's going on that's a good
question
it's completely different in that the
palestinian
land was taken from them to form the
state of israel
and the palestinians are landless the
republic of ireland seceded from the
united kingdom
and they have a their own state
they are they are a sovereign state um
northern ireland is
they have um the father mcmanus said
there is no government in northern
ireland
there's no government in scotland wales
or england either
because it is a unitary form of
government
and the seat of government as i
mentioned before is at westminster
and um the each
each state sends or each kingdom
sends their representatives to
that british parliament and they're all
british
maureen doesn't realize that she has
misstated the position
of the party she supports in northern
ireland the unionist party because the
unionist party and john molyneux
insists that there should be a local
government in northern ireland
at the present there is not however yes
so i did not mistake it
and and they want that change no mr
they want local governments strengthened
as in scotland wales they want to
parliament and
england and they do not in england they
don't they have local government they
have county governments city governments
town governments and they want to and
they want
excuse me
a stronger local government they used to
have an assembly
but they don't anymore they have can i
say something about you
i would welcome you in involvement i
would welcome
any outside catalyst because i believe
left to the triangle of
belfast dublin london there's going to
be no solution
and we have 70 years of proof i believe
the un
can play an important role i believe
america can play a key role
that's why we want president clinton to
fulfill his promise and appoint a
special envoy to northern ireland
because an outside catalyst can focus
the minds of the people there
it can focus the minds of the
international community
it can come as an honest broker and
dublin and belfast and london have
clearly given lots of proof
that they cannot solve it themselves we
need outside help
but they can't be successful can be
solved and it can be solved by the
terrorists
if the ira will lay down their arms
i as i understand it the loyalists said
they will lay theirs down also
so it's a terror campaign i mean the
question is about whether the u.n can
help i'm not too sure they can
president clinton himself was saying and
this has been american administration
policy since
jimmy carter that the solution has to
come from the people in northern ireland
and in the island of ireland um an
honest broker well i think the british
government and the irish governments at
the moment are desperately trying to be
honest brokers
and desperately trying to find a a a
solution that can satisfy
that can satisfy um one i'd better say
both groups but in fact we're confronted
by more than two groups in northern
ireland
um i think that one has to allow this
peace process to go ahead even though
i'm pessimistic about it
i think it will be a very fragile
process but one thing that has been
clear
over the last 25 years that after each
of one of these periods of negotiations
there has been almost a high water mark
there has been certain agreements made
and there's been no retreat from those
those agreements or those acceptances
of certain principles and so maybe we're
looking at a situation where we're going
to get the water rising
up and down again and then flowing up
further
but i think that outside um intervention
or interference is not going to help i
think it will provoke
more violence in northern ireland but
you see i
this what this concerns me about
people who essentially support the
british position in northern ireland
they have a double standard for
everything
the united nations has an important role
they'll say
all over the world america has an
important role all over the world
the international human rights community
has an important
role all over the world except one place
northern ireland
thou shalt not touch northern ireland
because you'll make matters worse
that is a false logic and i submit a
very suspect
logic because the bottom line is there
is that look
outside interference or attention will
embarrass
whom her majesty's government
and anything that embarrasses her
majesty's government
is taboo and that's the basic problem
i'm saying
it's time for america to apply a single
not a double standard to human rights if
discrimination in south africa is wrong
and it most surely is
then it's equally wrong in northern
ireland if the torture of prisoners
and the misuse of people in chile or
anyplace else is abhorrent to the us
congress then the same violations of
human rights
in northern ireland must be equally
abhorrent it's time for america
to take a stand and do the right thing
on this issue good thing i would like to
say
is that having lived in vietnam for five
years and having observed the united
nations
and as we see the united nations in
bosnia
and in in mogadishu etc
they do not play a very good role
in in any country that i have seen them
been
in and it's very important that since
the united kingdom
is a democratic society they must
solve their own problems president
clinton cannot send a
um a representative unless he is invited
to do so
and that is common courtesy between
sovereign states
let's go to our next question carmel
delanis from burbank california and this
question is directed to
everyone i was just wondering how the
economic
how the country's economic standard is
um being suffered
by because of this conflict in northern
ireland
in some ways it may be better off from
this conflict ironically
um britain subsidized northern ireland
to the tune of about 4.5 billion dollars
a year
there's been a tremendous uh effort to
try to develop
the economy in northern ireland um one
of the things that father mcmahon is
probably won't accept
uh but it is the case that most i would
think virtually every double and
politician would accept
is if you have a majority uh if you have
northern ireland forced into a unity
with the south
um and you force that majority to become
part of
the south there's going to be tremendous
economic problems for the irish republic
actually
uh it's a fragile economy uh they will
have tremendous costs
in fighting off probably protestant
paramilitaries who don't want to be part
of the
irish republic um but in the north uh
there's obviously i mean i was partly
not being totally frivolous about
northern ireland probably being better
off in the conflict because there are
obviously areas of uh
uh the the areas of the economy that
can't be developed because of this
fighting
like you know tourism would probably be
better off in northern ireland if there
wasn't a conflict but it has been a
tremendous amount of money pumped into
northern ireland
uh over the years by the british
government well i'm afraid while i see
some points in that i'm
i'm i'm i'm afraid it's a very um it's a
very negative
cynical attitude look
nor ireland is is is destroyed
by political instability and by violence
and by injustice
and oppression consequently
consequently the economy is a basket
case
in in a terrible situation and wherever
i'm speaking for the whole island it's a
destabilized economy north and south
and obviously one doesn't have to be an
economic genius
to know that a stable society is good
for the economy
people prosper in a stable society in a
just society
that's an agrarian society and they do
not have very much industry
northern ireland to the country has
contrary has always been
a very industrially developed developed
uh nation used to be they have they have
they you know they had the largest
shipbuilding works in the world they
have
they do during the war they had not any
longer
harland and wolf is not the largest ship
not a controller
heavily industrial just like and in
every society
we all need a detroit we need heavy
industry for
wealth and so ulster northern ireland
has always
been a heavy industry much more uh
industrial
than the republic where is that the
republic of ireland's
economy today is that of a third world
nation
and it couldn't exist except for the
funds it receives from
the european community maureen but your
impression of the irish republic
uh economy is extraordinary is it
may i just reply
in the last uh 15 20 years there's been
tremendous strides in the
in in the republic over its economy um
of course it's small it's a small
country three and a half million people
father mcmanus when i ask you something
though why
if i mean i would assume that you would
want the economies of northern ireland
and the republic
to thrive can i ask you why you then
oppose
and try to prevent american investment
in northern ireland
uh i do not of course you did in 1992
in 1986 you asked me a question now let
me answer it you asked my question
why do i oppose american investment i
most assuredly
do not oppose american investment i
promote and i favor an american
investment
in 1984 the irish national caucus
launched the mcbride principles
which is an affirmative action code of
conduct
a fair employment code of conduct for
american companies
doing business in northern ireland we
want american investment
but we want american firms to be
fair in their employment to take a stand
against the systematic
endemic anti-catholic discrimination in
northern ireland
and that has since 1984 uh mcbride has
been passed by 14 states into law
and over 50 cities and it has been the
most effective
campaign ever against anti-catholic
discrimination
in northern ireland and all experts
would agree
that it was the mcbride campaign more
than anything else that
prompted the british government to move
on discrimination
prompted the 1989 fair employment act
i would partly accept that and it's an
interesting area but for example in 1986
the shorts factory in northern ireland
about the biggest employer in northern
ireland
secured a contract from american an
american firm
which uh john hume nationalist mp head
of the social democratic and labour
party in northern ireland
help secure and you try to sabotage that
now as you well know fair employment
legislation was brought in by the
british in 1976
and again in 1989 and i would agree with
you
that it has been useful for uh people
to campaign and say uh employment
practices in northern ireland must be
improved on both sides of the community
because there's discrimination on both
sides of the community
um but it strikes me that
a lot of your campaigning and a lot of
your lobbying has actually been
unhelpful and it's the view of the irish
government and its view of john hume
and it's the view also of the four main
church leaders in northern ireland who
agreed a call for fair employment
uh very recently
which is endorsed by john major uh and
by the irish national caucus
i
you're not in disagreement with the
british government or john major who are
making as much strides as they can
in this particular practices
what what we believe here those who work
with me
we say look jewish americans
african-americans quite rightly and
quite nobly
get america to take a stand for their
homeland uh
south africa would not be on the verge
of democracy if it weren't for
african americans in this country and i
salute them for that
and i joined them outside the south
african embassy and i went to
prison i was the first catholic priest
to to go to jail for the
south african cause here in washington
and i salute them and i
salute what the jewish americans have
done for their homeland because without
them
israel probably wouldn't exist i am
simply saying and i base my work and
position on this
principle irish americans have a perfect
right
indeed a duty to get america to take a
stand for human rights in northern
ireland
i assume that means that irish americans
should join uh
ted kennedy or patrick monahu in
condemning
ira violence and condemning and
condemning
and condemning the disabilities of human
rights by terrorists
in the ira in inland and in the
protestant paramilitaries as well
and when you talk about human rights you
always mean
um you always mean the british
government is abusing human rights
um but you seem not to don't tell me
what i do
but you see me in your campaign but you
seem in your campaigning always to
concentrate on that
and never to concentrate on the on the
rights of uh
i do not kill it i do not deny it for a
minute if the audience thinks
that jewish groups and israel
and ireland and the republic of ireland
the united kingdom that they should all
interfere in the affairs of our
government
i think it would be very difficult
if this happened look all of these
countries have signed
international human rights agreement and
universal declaration on human rights
which means one thing very simple no
country in the world can say from then
on
that the treatment of their own citizens
is not the business of any other people
that's why we have a universal
declaration of human rights
that's why i have a duty to take a stand
for justice
not only in ireland but in south africa
or in chile
or in honduras or any place else in the
world
and it's only an anti-diluvian primitive
type of philosophy
that says mind your own business we can
torture our people
and it's none of your rights but out
that's nonsense
hello my name is yuri kambara from marin
county california and i was wondering
how each of you felt about john major
and how he compares to margaret thatcher
favorably but that wouldn't be hard
excuse me i think john major is a very
fine man and he certainly it's excuse me
he has a very large
act to follow in margaret thatcher
because she had so much power
and remember that margaret thatcher was
able to
rule uh as she as she did
rule her government as she did
britannia rude because you're a rude man
i think john mayer is a wimp he is no
he's a very fine man
because you think he's going to be able
to understand the republican cause i
think
he is very fair and i think if there was
an election today
possibly he would win again can i answer
that regardless of the
um can i answer that question in terms
of ireland
i i think what uh both john major and
albert reynolds the irish t chic
have have the big problem of living in
the shadow of their their predecessors
who were
in a sense much bigger politicians than
they are lady thatcher in britain and
charlie hockey
in in the republic um one of the things
that i suppose worries me about the
present priest process is that i think
they both see this as a chance of uh
in a sense redeeming their rather weak
premierships and i think that albert
reynolds for example
um uh was too keen too early to pray
to press the the the present peace
process
i think he raised expectations too high
for example in october he was talking
about
peace before christmas and as we know
we're a long way off piece yet
next question
hi my name is daniel voxel from john
brook well burbank california
and um before we came here we were
talking about religion
and my question was do you feel that if
northern ireland secedes from the uk and
becomes part of ireland
that the protestant will be persecuted
by the catholics yes i would agree
wholeheartedly with you this is
what would happen and remember that um
in the republic of ireland at one time
was 90 percent
uh roman catholic and that was in 1921.
today it's 98 a roman catholic state
while the people in ulster in northern
ireland and
in the united kingdom they
have many advantages
that they do not have in a
a theocratic state i think the
the the protestants of northern ireland
would find it very difficult
to join the republic of ireland i think
it's one of their fears obviously
um but i think that there's a lot
of uh misperception on each side about
the other
uh you're dealing with for example a man
like doctor ian paisley the fire brand
uh a preacher who's the head of the
democratic unionist party
who speaks in in in language which will
be more appropriate for the 17th century
uh who talks about the pope being uh you
know the
the [ __ ] of babylon um i
the idea of the uh the the uh the
southern irish persecuting uh
protestants because they're protestant i
find uh absurd but that is a genuine
fear in northern ireland
uh amongst a sizable body of protestants
and they do and they do look they do
look towards the the south and see that
there has been um
a falling off in the numbers of
protestants over the years in the
republic
uh you see the the the the awful problem
of the partition of ireland
is that it created two religious
monoliths
in the south that created a pan-catholic
state 95
catholic in the north it created a
protestant state for a protestant people
now that british act institutionalized
religious divergence and difference what
i want to see in ireland
is religious pluralism i i think
maureen's
antiquated anti-catholic bigotry is
deplorable
because nobody believes that that
protestants would be persecuted no
enlightened person now paisley exploits
people i am a supporter
of integrated schools where they said
that the protestants would be persecuted
in southern they most certainly figured
no it's not what would you call it then
let me say that in northern ireland the
catholic population
is 45 of the population
but when it comes to voting uh
those catholics excuse me those catholic
politicians
only get about talk to me 28
of the vote the ira gets 10 of them i'm
not talking about the ira
both the ira and the nationalist
politicians are both
very minor parties mourinho my question
is why do you also the churches
in why do you think the protestants
would be persecuted in southern ireland
please answer that question i'll answer
your questions the churches
and i'm answering a question here the
churches in
northern ireland are extremely
united why would the protestants be you
are
behind in southern ireland find that
there's
someone in the audience ask her that
question yes and she'll answer it
why do you why does she think the
protestants would be oppressed
in southern ireland ask that question
please first and foremost
they do not have schools
oh no yeah why do you think protestants
would be
praying i know paisley does but do you
think that the protestants would be
oppressed
in southern ireland and why i think they
would have a very difficult time
i think they would have a very difficult
time in jobs
there wouldn't be any schools for them
how could the republic of ireland
provide the excellent schools that
northern ireland has the best schools in
the in the united states i think she's
talking my question isn't she get that
impression
to our next student question go ahead hi
my name is janie
i'm from minneapolis minnesota um this
question is directed to any one of you
um
i'm interested in knowing where the ira
and the uda receive their funds
they received most of their fronts from
their own racketeering practices in
northern ireland and in the republic as
well
i assume you asked that question because
you're reading the harper's
magazine article which i think was in
your information pack where is it to
believe that
is that why you asked the question no he
said
no i mean the harpers i i mentioned the
harpers because there's the implication
in the article that everyone is doing
this
all the parameters on both sides are
doing this because they're making lots
of money
and the article confuses um two things
money and motivation
in terms of money a paramilitary
organization needs money to survive
the ira probably needs between about 12
million and 15 million dollars
to continue uh running each year they
have to pay
very small amounts mind you to their
three four hundred uh
frontline gunmen to the 600 or so
people around them who are giving extra
support they have to finance shin fein
the headquarters in belfast londonderry
dublin
they have to buy explosives and arms
they have to
keep a general staff in dublin they have
to finance
active active missions abroad in in
europe and britain and altogether that
cost you i mean 915 million dollars
in the same way the protestant
paramilitaries need money
to um to survive as well and most of
that comes from
racketeering it comes from extortion uh
it comes from protection money that they
demand
uh it comes from a fleet of taxi cabs
that both sides
own in belfast it comes from gaming
machines
and it comes from pubs and clubs and
some of it comes from
from legitimate organizations in one
sense it's a bit like the mafia
in that uh you know you begin you begin
illegitimately
and then you can put your money into
legitimate organizations as well is any
of that money received from outside
yes i mean um it's been calculated and
it's very hard to calculate how much
money has come from irish americans
um the there's one calculation i saw of
about three to five million dollars
since 1971
uh has been provided by irish americans
which has gone into
uh the republican movement no raid is
the main
collector of money over here
nor raid always claims that none of its
money goes towards the purchasing of
weapons in northern ireland and that the
money only goes towards
welfare of the families of imprisoned
ira men
it is very hard to prove either either
way whether that money has directly gone
to fund
gun running the purchase of weapons but
what it does do is indirectly support
the ira
because it allows the ira to shift some
of the money that they might use for
those families
welfare money for the families of
imprisoned ira men
back to purchasing weapons senator
robert kennedy
supported by patrick moynihan and hugh
carey back in 77 1977 issued a
statement on st patrick's day urging
americans not
to contribute to organizations which
were which were linked
in any way with parametry uh groups in
northern ireland
and senator edward kennedy said that it
shouldn't be on any irish-americans
conscience
uh that their efforts or their dollars
are leading to death in northern ireland
and i think that's right i agree with
that
it shouldn't be on that on the head of
any irish american
that he he or she causes death in
northern ireland but equally
and legislatively in the first place
it shouldn't be on the hands of any
english man and woman
who paid tax dollars to keep up a
sectarian
oppressive system in northern ireland
financing
and and training and equipping the
british army now
as regards you had your say as regards
loyalist terrorism who funds them
it mustn't be left out here that in many
documented cases we have
absolute proof like amnesty just rotary
porting it
but political killings in northern
ireland many times
when the loyalists take action they're
they're they're facilitated and equipped
very often with the help of british
intelligence and british army now
pick up the the most recent report by
amnesty international
just out political killings in northern
ireland where it
cites the british government for
collusion
for cooperating and helping and arming
the protestant terror gangs to kill
catholics first of all it doesn't
actually say that the report
what the what the report condemns is the
collusion
between sections and elements in the
ouster police force
and sections within the uda of helping
protest
intelligence no you didn't you said
british intelligence and british
government we're talking about
individuals and all those three
organizations
no that's not no that's an important
distinction
the intelligence operates without the
british government come on
now you look join me in this okay i will
admit
that there's many problems from the
catholic side in northern ireland
i have denounced the ira unequivocally i
want
this gentleman to unequivocally denounce
the the murder and killing and the
oppression and injustice conducted
by her majesty's government in northern
ireland will you do that
i'll answer that question if you allow
me will you condemn it you ask
will you condemn the british government
right here right
now shut up for a second you might hear
my reply
do it my reply is that in
insight magazine washington times
recently i wrote
that one of the most disturbing elements
in the last few years in northern
ireland
has been the growth of the protestant
paramilitary groups and the collusion by
elements with those groups by
individuals within the
udr the asset defense regiment part of
the british army
uh an irish regiment and in the ruc
what i will now what about the
government what i will not do the
stalker affair
let's i'm not talking about protestants
it's easy to condemn
do you contem the british government for
its human rights violations of northern
ireland
yes or no yeah yes or no
yes but i didn't hear it yes or no hold
on if you let me finish
i will condemn i will condemn the
shadowy
shoot to kill policy by sections within
the ouster police force
and by sections within the british army
of course i will i think it's profoundly
unhelpful
and i think it's immoral
ahead because one thing that you do not
allow these people to understand is the
whole dynamic of what is happening in
northern ireland
one of the one of the tragedies one of
the awful patterns in this long tapestry
of violence
is that you have a terrorist
organization who's many who's are many
times
organizations including the british army
who's and let's just let's just
concentrate
on the ira for a second you're doing
that i want you to introduce a new
element
a couple of seconds left so if i could
ask you each for a final it
the ira cries crocodile tears
a terrorist organization in a democratic
society wishes to provoke
illiberal harsh reactions by democratic
government unfortunately
the british government over the last 25
years has often
and all too often allowed that to happen
um the guildford four case the
birmingham six case
uh were deeply damaging uh to uh
protestant interest in northern ireland
to british interests
uh in ireland as well um but the ira
must share
its blame for the corrosion of the
judicial system in northern ireland
one more that the ira has its
headquarters
in the republic of ireland and from the
republic of ireland
they commit murder across the border and
i haven't heard that mentioned
i the violence of the british government
of the
ira the violence of every group who's
using violence in northern ireland
must cease there cannot be peace for
islam
as the british government and the ira
and the protestant
loyalists paramilitaries commit violence
okay thank you very much for your
comments here we're totally out of time
thank you for your questions and
comments join us again next week